Hi everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Kim Mills was a guest host. We hope you enjoy this episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the role of psychology in everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills.
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在2019年10月于华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会（APA）“技术、思维与社会”会议期间录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。你好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探讨心理学在日常生活中的作用。我是主持人金·米尔斯。
My guest today is Dr. Gregory Kratzig, an adjunct professor of psychology at the University of Regina in Saskatchewan, Canada, and a global expert in simulation-based training, particularly in the world of law enforcement. He has used virtual reality to train first responders to drive emergency vehicles and to help police officers make the best decisions when they're faced with choosing whether to use force. I don't think it's a stretch to say that virtual reality is revolutionizing how we train people in law enforcement as well as in other fields such as aviation and medicine. So thank you for joining us today, Dr. Kratzik. Thank you very much for having me.
我今天的嘉宾是加拿大萨斯喀彻温省里贾纳大学的心理学兼职教授格雷戈里·克拉齐格（Gregory Kratzig）博士，他也是模拟训练领域的全球专家，尤其是在执法领域。他利用虚拟现实技术训练急救人员驾驶紧急车辆，并帮助警察在面临是否使用武力时做出最佳决策。我认为说虚拟现实正在彻底改变执法部门以及航空和医学等其他领域的培训方式，一点也不夸张。所以，感谢您今天加入我们，克拉齐格博士。非常感谢您的邀请。
So let's start by having you tell our listeners a little about the research you've conducted, specifically training law enforcement officers. How are you using simulations? Why are they well suited to training police? We've been using simulation technology in the use of force area. So the video-based technology, law enforcement's been using that for, you know, about three decades now. And it's evolved over time.
那么，首先请您向我们的听众介绍一下您所进行的研究，特别是针对执法人员的培训。您是如何使用模拟技术的？为什么它们非常适合警察培训？我们一直在武力使用领域使用模拟技术。执法部门使用基于视频的技术已经有大约三十年了，而且它随着时间的推移不断演变。
It's getting much better. But more recently, we're now using simulation for firearms training and driving simulation. And what that provides us is an opportunity to train both police recruits as well as existing police officers in an environment that's safe.
它正在变得越来越好。但最近，我们开始将模拟技术用于枪支训练和驾驶模拟。这为我们提供了一个在安全环境中培训新警员和在职警员的机会。
So what I mean by that is we can't teach emergency response driving. So clearing intersections, driving, you know, lights and sirens through the city streets in our city or any other city. But we can do that using simulation. So we can introduce opposing traffic, pedestrians, animals, anything that we want to. And when something happens, you know, that's a teaching moment. We can talk to the recruit, what they did right, what they did wrong, why certain things happen to cause the collision.
我的意思是，我们无法在现实中教授紧急响应驾驶，比如在我们的城市或任何其他城市的街道上，开着警灯和警笛穿过十字路口。但我们可以通过模拟来实现。我们可以引入对向交通、行人、动物，任何我们想要的元素。当发生情况时，这就是一个教学时刻。我们可以与新警员讨论他们做对了什么，做错了什么，以及为什么某些事情会导致碰撞。
And then we hit the reset and we allow them to do it again. something that you absolutely can't do in the real world. Firearms is another area. It also allows us to train our recruits in a very safe environment. So they don't have to, you know, when you hold a live weapon, there's a certain anxiety that comes along with it. And it kind of takes away from building of the skill itself of learning how to shoot a gun. So we can remove that, focus on the actual skill acquisition,
然后我们重置，让他们再做一次，这在现实世界中是绝对做不到的。枪支是另一个领域。它也让我们能够在非常安全的环境中训练新警员。所以他们不必，你知道，当你拿着真枪时，会伴随着某种焦虑。这在某种程度上削弱了学习射击这项技能本身的过程。所以我们可以消除这种焦虑，专注于实际的技能习得，
and then introduce the live fire later on. and that anxiety seems to really dissipate. But I understand that there's some resistance to this marksmanship training. Is that coming from gun manufacturers? Is it coming from police departments? What's behind that? It's definitely coming from the end user for sure.
然后再进行实弹射击，那种焦虑似乎真的消散了。但我了解到，对于这种射击训练存在一些抵触情绪。这是来自枪支制造商吗？还是来自警察局？这背后的原因是什么？这绝对是来自终端用户，毫无疑问。
You know, there's this long-held belief that a bullet needs to come out of a gun and needs to recoil, you need to smell the cordite in order to learn how to shoot. But if you learn all of the skills, the way you need to learn them. If you do that correctly, the bullet's going to go where you want it to go all the time anyways. Everything happens after, everything happens before the bullet comes out of the gun itself.
你知道，人们长期以来一直认为，子弹必须从枪里射出，必须有后坐力，必须闻到火药味才能学会射击。但如果你以需要的方式学习所有技能，如果你做得正确，子弹总是会射向你想让它去的地方。一切都发生在子弹射出枪膛之前。
So the resistance is coming from those in the field that really are a resistant of changing something that really hasn't changed how we teach firearms training for the past 100 years. And do people become more adept at marksmanship by going through it virtual? first. I mean, can you demonstrate that there's a, you know, a good reason for doing this in addition to what you've just described? Absolutely. We have, we've conducted a number of studies with the RCMP. It has been replicated down here in the United States and with another agency in Canada. And we have removed all of the live fire practice from our training program for this research only and demonstrated that the skills are acquired, that the skills transfer from the
所以抵触情绪来自那些在实地工作的人，他们真的抵触改变过去100年来我们教授枪支训练的方式。那么，通过虚拟训练，人们在射击方面会变得更熟练吗？我的意思是，除了您刚才描述的内容之外，您能证明这样做有充分的理由吗？当然可以。我们与加拿大皇家骑警（RCMP）进行了一些研究。这项研究在美国和加拿大的另一个机构得到了复制。为了这项研究，我们从培训项目中取消了所有的实弹射击练习，并证明了技能是可以习得的，技能可以从
simulator to the live fire environment, and we have evidence that actually shows that the retention of the skill is nominally better than if they were trained in a fully traditional live fire setting. So one of the factors that you also study is physiological arousal and how it affects decision-making in law enforcement situations. I think it's pretty well understood that policing can be a a very hazardous line of work, which means that police officers may experience hypervigilance
模拟器转移到实弹射击环境。我们有证据表明，技能的保持力实际上比在完全传统的实弹射击环境中训练要好。那么，您研究的因素之一还有生理唤醒及其如何影响执法情况下的决策。我认为人们普遍理解，警务工作可能是一项非常危险的工作，这意味着警察可能会经历过度警觉
and other forms of physiological arousal. When is this a good thing and when is this bad for an officer in the field? Oh, that's a really good question. And it's quite complicated. So what we've done, I mean, over the last, you know, I'm just going to say the last 10 years, we've developed different scenarios, both in the simulator and live in our police defensive tactics,
以及其他形式的生理唤醒。这对一线警官来说，什么时候是好事，什么时候是坏事？哦，这是一个非常好的问题。而且非常复杂。所以我们所做的是，在过去，我想说过去10年里，我们开发了不同的场景，无论是在模拟器中还是在我们的警察防御战术实战中，
that try and replicate what could actually happen in the real world. And so trying to stop a threat of some sort, whether you're going to arrest them or if it's an active shooter situation. So we build these scenarios, and we believe that they're complicated for that particular recruit at a point in time and training. But we don't, and we also then believe that they are eliciting, you know, emotional responses and cognitive demand on our recruits.
试图复制现实世界中可能发生的情况。比如试图阻止某种威胁，无论你是要逮捕他们，还是在活跃枪手的情况下。所以我们构建了这些场景，我们认为对于当时处于培训阶段的特定新警员来说，这些场景很复杂。但我们并不，我们也认为它们正在引发新警员的情绪反应和认知需求。
But we really don't have the evidence. to suggest that that's actually the case. So one of the reasons why we want to use the physiological equipment is to actually look at that. Are we getting the type of output that we believe that we are when we design a scenario that we're supposed to get? So that's one. The second thing that we want to make sure that we're doing
但我们确实没有证据表明情况确实如此。所以我们想要使用生理监测设备的原因之一就是为了实际观察这一点。当我们设计一个场景时，我们是否得到了我们认为应该得到的输出？这是第一点。第二点是我们想要确保
is that if there is a high level of emotional arousal, and if we can demonstrate with the equipment that there is a large cognitive demand, that we can then incorporate additional tools in the training program for them to be able to work through that emotional arousal and to be able to resolve whatever's in front of them in a better way, I guess, in a quicker, safer way for both the police officer and the suspect that they're dealing with. So those are a couple of things. We also know that when you are talking about PTSD or other occupational stress injuries, that it's not just a couple of things. that it's not just one traumatic event that necessarily causes that.
如果存在高水平的情绪唤醒，并且如果我们能用设备证明存在巨大的认知需求，那么我们就可以在培训项目中加入额外的工具，让他们能够克服这种情绪唤醒，并以更好的方式，我想是以更快、更安全的方式解决他们面前的问题，这对警察和他们处理的嫌疑人都有好处。所以这是几点。我们也知道，当谈到创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或其他职业压力伤害时，不仅仅是几件事，
It could be this notion of a thousand or several hundred different traumatic events that are smaller in nature, but it's just all of a sudden it's that one that actually becomes that trigger. So the other thing that we want to do is to try and provide them with the tools to manage their stresses as they go through their career in an effort to try and mitigate the effects of PTSD. So what are some of those tools? Is it cognitive behavioral therapy? Is it, you know, what are you giving to police officers? Yeah, we are, we are trying some mindfulness training with some cadets. We're doing a research project with them right now. We are also looking at doing augmented training with a number of cadets starting next year. And it's a program that was developed out of Harvard and Boston University. So we're looking and incorporating that into our program. And so think about cognitive
不一定是由一个创伤性事件引起的。这可能是所谓的成百上千个较小的创伤性事件，突然之间，就是那一个事件成为了触发点。所以我们想做的另一件事是尝试为他们提供工具，以管理他们在职业生涯中遇到的压力，从而努力减轻PTSD的影响。那么这些工具是什么？是认知行为疗法吗？您给警察提供了什么？是的，我们正在尝试对一些学员进行正念训练。我们现在正在与他们进行一个研究项目。我们还计划从明年开始对一些学员进行增强训练。这是一个由哈佛大学和波士顿大学开发的项目。所以我们正在考虑并将其纳入我们的计划中。想想认知
behavior therapy, you're absolutely right. But instead of giving CBT and these tools to a person after they're injured, let's give it to them before they're injured to be some sort of a preventative mitigating instrument to manage those stresses. So body cameras and dashboard cameras have been very much in the news lately. I'm just wondering, are these included in your training and if so, How? No, they're not. We do not have not used body-worn cameras at all in my agency, and we're 25,000 police officers, and to date we've made a decision not to use them. We're still examining it, but as of right now, we don't use body-worn cameras, so I haven't worked with that technology. Is that less prevalent in Canada than it is in the U.S., do you think? Yes, it is. Yeah, it's pretty,
行为疗法，你说得完全正确。但与其在人受伤后才提供认知行为疗法和这些工具，不如在他们受伤前就提供，作为一种预防性的缓解手段来管理这些压力。那么随身摄像头和行车记录仪最近在新闻中出现得很多。我只是想知道，这些是否包含在您的培训中？如果是，是如何包含的？不，没有。我的机构根本没有使用随身摄像头，我们有25,000名警察，到目前为止，我们决定不使用它们。我们仍在研究，但目前我们不使用随身摄像头，所以我没有使用过这项技术。您认为这在加拿大是否比在美国更不普遍？是的，确实。是的，它非常，
becoming very widely used here in this country. Yeah, there's still lots of agencies that don't that don't use it. What's the reason, do you know? I think there's a number of, I think privacy is one, for sure. Costs is another one. You know, storage of the videos is tremendously expensive and cataloging. So there's a number of different factors that have to be considered. So can you give a description of how you use simulators to train police and first responders
在这个国家正变得非常广泛地使用。是的，仍然有很多机构不使用它。你知道原因吗？我认为有很多原因，隐私肯定是一个。成本是另一个。你知道，视频的存储和编目非常昂贵。所以有很多不同的因素需要考虑。那么您能描述一下您是如何使用模拟器来培训警察和急救人员
how to drive? What's different about driving when you're a cop? Oh, yeah. So we take the skills, assuming that a recruit is coming into the academy with some sort of civilian driving skills. And we take those skills and then build upon that. So we introduce a police driving. So what that basically is giving them the tools in which to do this environmental scan. So they're always supposed to be scanning the environment, looking for things that are out of place.
如何驾驶的吗？警察驾驶有什么不同？哦，是的。所以我们采用这些技能，假设新警员进入学院时已经具备某种平民驾驶技能。我们采用这些技能，然后在此基础上进行构建。所以我们引入了警察驾驶。这基本上是给他们提供进行环境扫描的工具。所以他们应该始终扫描环境，寻找不寻常的事物。
So they don't have to be in a pursuit drive. they don't have to be going to emergency call, they just need to be aware of their environment, scanning back and forth and backing forth, looking for those things that are out of place. And so those are what we're trying to do. As a civilian driver, we don't do that. We're just focusing on what's in front of us, more or less,
所以他们不必处于追捕驾驶状态，也不必去处理紧急呼叫，他们只需要意识到周围的环境，来回扫描，寻找那些不寻常的事物。这就是我们试图做的。作为平民司机，我们不这样做。我们或多或少只关注我们面前的东西，
going from point out of point B, and it's a very unconscious drive. Think about when you go to the grocery store, you don't really remember the journey to get there. You just remember getting there. For a police officer, they are needing to look at the entire, environment always looking for those things someone who may need help or
从A点到B点，这是一种非常无意识的驾驶。想想你去杂货店的时候，你并不真正记得去那里的过程。你只记得到了那里。对于警察来说，他们需要观察整个环境，始终寻找那些可能需要帮助的人，或者
anything that's out of place and that's those are the kind of skills that we're trying to give them but while they're doing that we also need to make sure that they also have the proper vehicle position so as they're driving they don't want to get boxed in behind a car just in case they need to go respond to emergency so vehicle positioning being aware of where the traffic is and always allowing themselves a way out of a situation so they can get to to the respondent's call. So that's kind of in a nutshell
任何不寻常的事物，这就是我们试图给他们的技能。但在他们这样做的时候，我们还需要确保他们有正确的车辆位置，这样当他们开车时，他们不会被困在车后，以防他们需要去响应紧急情况。所以车辆定位、意识到交通在哪里，并始终为自己留出脱离困境的路径，这样他们才能赶到响应呼叫的地点。所以这简而言之就是
what we're trying to teach the cadets. It's a lot to be thinking about all at once. It's a kind of multitasking. Absolutely. And then you throw a dispatcher on there, you know, so they throw in a license plate that, you know, can you do a check on this? And while they're still scanning back and forth,
我们试图教给学员的内容。这需要同时考虑很多事情。这是一种多任务处理。绝对是。然后你再给他们加上调度员，你知道，他们会报出一个车牌号，问你能不能查一下？而当他们还在来回扫描时，
trying to understand where their vehicle is in the traffic, and then they got their computer on their side, and that's going off. So there's lots of things, that lots of cognitive demands on a police officer. for sure. So we're trying to introduce those skills slowly in a simulator, do the confirmation in the live environment, come back, introduce another skill. And so we kind of go back and forth, kind of think of scaffolding. So we're just kind of building and building on those skills.
试图了解他们的车辆在交通中的位置，然后他们旁边的电脑响了。所以有很多事情，对警察有很多认知需求。当然。所以我们试图在模拟器中慢慢引入这些技能，在真实环境中进行确认，回来，再引入另一种技能。所以我们有点来回往复，可以把它看作是脚手架。我们只是在这些技能的基础上不断构建。
And even though we haven't researched this anecdotally from our instructors, they're telling us that those cadets are coming into their respective parts of the program, much better equipped after they come into the simulator. So it's allowing us to introduce a certain set of skills. That's a lot to be thinking about, though. I mean, it's almost like you're having to learn how to effectively text and drive. I mean, it sounds like it's very dangerous, really. Absolutely. You know, there's lots of discussion about distracted driving, and yet we're telling our police officers you need to do distracted driving. Yeah. But there's also a method to that. So when they're on the radio, there's certain points on the drive, especially when the driving lights and sirens
即使我们没有对此进行研究，但从我们的教官那里得到的轶事反馈是，他们告诉我们，这些学员在进入模拟器后，进入各自的培训阶段时准备得充分多了。所以这让我们能够引入一套特定的技能。但这需要考虑的事情太多了。我的意思是，这几乎就像你必须学习如何有效地边发短信边开车。听起来真的很危险。绝对是。你知道，关于分心驾驶有很多讨论，然而我们却告诉我们的警察，你们需要进行分心驾驶。是的。但这也是有方法的。所以当他们在无线电上时，在驾驶的某些点上，特别是在开着警灯和警笛
somewhere when you don't use your radio. So don't use it when you're just going into an intersection. If a dispatcher calls you, they don't know exactly where you are, go on the radio as soon as you exit that intersection and go into the main way because in that safer, there's a lot going on that intersection. And when you're going through red light, all the civilian traffic, they have the right away going green. So if there's a collision, the police officer is the one that created that collision, not the civilian population. So they have to then deal with that situation. So the dispatcher just give them two or three seconds, then get back on the radio, and then respond to the dispatcher. So we also teach them that. Yes, there's lots of things going on, but take a
去某个地方时，不要使用无线电。所以当你刚进入十字路口时不要使用它。如果调度员呼叫你，他们不知道你确切在哪里，等你离开那个十字路口进入主干道后再使用无线电，因为那里更安全，十字路口有很多情况。当你闯红灯时，所有的平民车辆都有绿灯通行权。所以如果发生碰撞，是警察造成了那次碰撞，而不是平民。所以他们必须处理那种情况。所以调度员只需给他们两三秒钟，然后再回到无线电上，响应调度员。所以我们也教他们这一点。是的，有很多事情在发生，但要休息一下，安全通过，然后再使用无线电。在您的工作中还有其他您想讨论的发现，或者您在APA会议上谈论过的发现吗？我们也在虚拟现实方面做了很多工作。我们真的认为虚拟现实绝对是警察培训的未来方向。我们是一个更大的工作组的一部分，这是一个国际小组，包括英国、美国、澳大利亚和我们，致力于将虚拟现实
break, get through safely, and then go on the radio. Any other findings in your work that you want to discuss or that you've been talking about here at the APA conference? We've also been doing quite a bit of work with virtual reality. We really believe that virtual reality is definitely the way of the future for police training. We're part of a larger working group, international group, UK, US, and Australia and us working on virtual reality. as a training tool. We all have a little bit of expertise. Nobody has everything.
作为一种培训工具。我们每个人都有一些专长。没有人拥有全部。
And then we've partnered with academia to help us out, build virtual reality scenarios mostly right now for beta testing. We're hoping to get them into the program by the end of the year so that we could do some actual empirical studies on virtual reality. But when you think about simulation,
然后我们与学术界合作来帮助我们，构建虚拟现实场景，目前主要是为了进行Beta测试。我们希望在年底前将它们纳入计划，以便我们能够对虚拟现实进行一些实际的实证研究。但当你想到模拟时，
these driving simulators are massive pieces of technical. They're very expensive. And you should be able to do the same thing in a virtual world for a fraction of the cost, but it's much, much more immersive. And that's where we want to end up, is creating something as realistic as we can, what they might experience in the real world. So that's where we're putting a lot of energy into virtual reality right now. So what are some of the other scenarios? I mean, it's not always a shoot-don't-shoot situation.
这些驾驶模拟器是巨大的技术设备。它们非常昂贵。你应该能够在虚拟世界中以极低的成本做同样的事情，而且它更具沉浸感。这就是我们想要达到的目标，即创造出尽可能逼真的场景，模拟他们在现实世界中可能经历的事情。所以这就是我们现在投入大量精力研究虚拟现实的原因。那么还有哪些其他场景呢？我的意思是，并不总是开枪或不开枪的情况。
It could be, I don't know, you're making a call for domestic violence. Absolutely. we're doing domestic violence. We've replicated our drug house in virtual reality, a mental health scenario where a person who is in crisis and we're interacting with that individual to calm them down and get them the help that they need. So it's not just shoot, don't shoot. Very few of our scenarios are that. Most of ours are de-escalation. Virtually almost, virtually all of our calls for service are are not violent in nature. They're they're really easily de-escalated and they usually resolve without incidents. And that's what we're really focusing on the de-escalation part, especially with
可能是，我不知道，你接到一个家庭暴力的报警。绝对是。我们正在做家庭暴力。我们在虚拟现实中复制了我们的毒窝，一个心理健康场景，其中一个人处于危机中，我们正在与那个人互动以让他们冷静下来，并为他们提供所需的帮助。所以不仅仅是开枪或不开枪。我们的场景中很少有这种情况。我们的大多数场景都是关于降级处理的。几乎，几乎我们所有的服务呼叫都不是暴力性质的。它们真的很容易降级，通常在没有事件的情况下就能解决。这就是我们真正关注的降级部分，特别是在
the mental health. That's one area that we're putting more time in. And I think virtual reality is going to really help us with that. Yeah, that's a place where psychology can really, really play a role. Do you think that it's getting better? I mean, I know that it's been problematic for years with police not being able to effectively determine whether a person in crisis is going to be violent or there's a way to talk to a person who's got some kind of a mental issue or mental illness? Well, I think that's a larger social issue. I think we've put a lot on police officers. I mean, they're a first responder, but they're responding not only to crimes, but they're responding to, you know, all of these mental health. And we're expecting them to be able to diagnose somebody
心理健康方面。这是我们投入更多时间的一个领域。我认为虚拟现实真的会在这方面帮助我们。是的，这是心理学真正可以发挥作用的地方。您认为情况正在好转吗？我的意思是，我知道多年来一直存在问题，警察无法有效地判断处于危机中的人是否会变得暴力，或者是否有办法与有某种心理问题或精神疾病的人交谈？嗯，我认为这是一个更大的社会问题。我认为我们给警察施加了太大的压力。我的意思是，他们是急救人员，但他们不仅响应犯罪，他们还响应，你知道，所有这些心理健康问题。我们期望他们能够诊断某人
almost as soon as they get on the state, oh, yeah, you must have schizophrenia. you have bipolar disorder, well, they're not trained for that. And so we need to help give them some tools to be able to identify someone who might be in mental health crisis or substance abuse or whatever it might be so that they can get that person to help. But we're just asking our police to do more and more and more and more. And they're really not equipped. I think they do a fine job. They do a great job with the tools they have, but we need to find a way to give them more tools,
几乎在他们到达现场时就说，哦，是的，你一定患有精神分裂症。你有双相情感障碍，好吧，他们没有接受过这方面的培训。所以我们需要帮助他们提供一些工具，以便能够识别可能处于心理健康危机或药物滥用或其他任何情况的人，这样他们就可以让那个人得到帮助。但我们只是要求我们的警察做更多、更多、更多的事情。他们真的没有配备相应的装备。我认为他们做得很好。他们用现有的工具做得很好，但我们需要找到一种方法给他们更多的工具，
better tools to be able to do their job. Is what you're doing then being shared with the training academies? Yes, yeah. Everything that I belong to a couple of different groups, international groups, and all of our information is disseminated during some of those meetings, as well as the senior leadership within our organization. They meet with senior leaders throughout the world on a regular basis, and that information is also shared at the very, very top level.
更好的工具来完成他们的工作。那么您所做的工作是否正在与培训学院分享？是的，是的。我所属的几个不同的团体，国际团体，我们所有的信息都会在这些会议期间传播，以及我们组织内部的高层领导。他们定期与世界各地的高层领导会面，这些信息也会在最高层进行分享。
So there's lots of opportunities to disseminate this information, and we do. As soon as it becomes available, we absolutely. And then we also take information from our partners as well on the work that they're doing and see if we can apply to our own agency. This is all really interesting and very important work, so thank you and thanks for joining us today.
所以有很多机会传播这些信息，我们确实在这样做。一旦信息可用，我们绝对会分享。然后我们也从我们的合作伙伴那里获取关于他们正在做的工作的信息，看看我们是否可以将其应用到我们自己的机构中。这一切都非常有趣且非常重要，所以谢谢您，也感谢您今天加入我们。
Great. Thank you very much for having me and thank you very much for your interest. So I just want to remind our listeners that we, at Speaking of Psychology, want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas for future episodes, to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. It's really helpful.
太棒了。非常感谢您的邀请，也非常感谢您的关注。所以我想提醒我们的听众，我们《心理学谈话》希望听到你们的声音。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和对未来节目的想法发送到 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。请在iTunes上给我们评分。这真的很有帮助。
Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other informative podcasts such as APA journals Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and you can also go to our website, www. speakingofpsychology.org and listen to more episodes. Thanks for listening. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他信息丰富的播客，例如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue）和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》（Progress Notes）。你可以在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客，你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。